Speaker 1: All right. Let's get to the
mailbag for the week. Info at David
Pakman dot com. I don't know if it's because
it's election week or what happened this week,
but some really just like extra wacky stuff came
in. And of course, you all know, I love to address
substantive critiques. Let's start with a message
from Silky about why I'm a coward and a hypocrite.
Okay. Silky says Hello, Pacman fever. Da da da.
Now, I don't know. I saw your recent video where
you watched the Fetterman Oz debate and you really
showed your hypocrisy when you admonished people
in your chat for saying things you didn't like
about Fetterman because you hate your audience.
That didn't happen. What I said was the
people overtly making fun of the fact
that he had a stroke that was in poor taste.
And I stand by. That person goes on to say,
mainly questioning his mental faculties, which
is a valid concern. Okay. That's not what they
were doing. What's interesting, though, right,
Silky, is you're constantly saying similar things
about Trump. Lake, Marjorie, Taylor. GREENE
and other conservatives, even Tulsi Gabbard,
questioning their mental state and health. That
is not true. That is not true. This is a person
who has not actually listened to what I've said.
When it comes to Trump. We have had long time
concerns about the glitching and the twitching
and the, you know, getting confused about what's
coming out of his mouth saying we need to look
into the oranges of the investigation. And he
looks confused and he can't get the word he
wants. With, you know, Rudy Giuliani sitting
in front of him and he starts looking around,
where is Rudy? Where's Rudy? Three feet away.
That's Trump Ock Lake and Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
It's a disconnection from reality and a sort of
radicalized ignorance. So it's it's different.
I've never thought that Lake and Marjorie Taylor
GREENE were having cognitive issues. I think
they're nuts. I think they're dangerous. But
in any case, this is, as usual, someone who is
reacting to things I haven't said. And Tulsi,
I've never talked about Tulsi in this context.
And lastly, Silky says and in vain with that,
I think you mean in that vein, why don't you
invite some of these people on to your show?
You do have a large enough platform. If they truly
are as mentally unstable as you constantly claim,
you should have no issue debunking their arguments
or making them out to be fools. But you won't
because you're a coward. We've invited all
of these people. They refuse to come on.
I had Ben SHAPIRO on some years ago. It was
fine. It didn't go great for him, but it was
it was a fine. It was hugely embarrassing.
He's refused to come back on ever since.
So they are invited. And people say, David, you
criticize Jordan Peterson. Why not have him on?
I've had him on and we've invited him multiple
times. He refuses to come on. Okay. So come on,
guys. Try to try to just be a little bit more
reasonable in these emails. Patrick wrote in,
who also writes in as Donna all that. I guess
it's Donna writing in as someone named Patrick.
I don't know. And Donna says, Dave, you can spin
it any way you want. I live in upstate New York,
and oil and electric prices have tripled and
winter is not even here. Groceries through the
roof. If we don't become energy independent again,
it will it will get worse economically. Everyone
knows that energy is the heart of our survival. So
spin it over and over again. I still listen to you
once in a while. Yet this is this is someone who
just doesn't know what's happening. First of all,
if you said to someone. What does it mean to be
energy independent? What do you think they would
say? I think a lot of people, if you said energy
independence, they would say we domestically
produce all of the energy we use. Now, when Trump
has been talking about energy independence, he's
not even talking about that. Trump's talking about
the import export numbers specifically for oil.
That's what Trump is talking about. And in the
last couple of years of Trump, as well as in the
first year of Biden, the U.S. roughly exported as
much oil as we imported. That's what they mean by
energy independence. So two things. One, it's not
really energy independence. It's talking about the
trade balance on oil. And two, it hasn't really
changed since Joe Biden replaced Donald Trump.
Do you think Donna has any idea about that? I
think the answer is no. Do you think, Don, his
mind would be changed if I presented her with this
information or him if it's Patrick? I don't know.
I think the answer is clearly no. Mimi wrote
in about a free membership and says, Hello,
Mr. Pacman, good evening. I would love to have
a free membership, but can't afford it. I'm on
a fixed income. I want you to know. Keep doing
what you're doing. Keep up the good work. Okay?
I've said this 100 times before. Mimi, we love
you here. Let me once get on the record how to get
free memberships. Okay. You can't email me about
it. You go to David Pakman dot com slash free
membership. There's three fields to
put in. First name. Last name. Email.
You put your name on the list in order, we will
give out the free memberships. You'll be notified
by email. Do not email about the free memberships.
Go to David Pakman dot com. Slash free membership.
They're available. Timothy wrote in about phone
banking. This is a really important email.
Yo, David, you say phone banking is important
and I agree. The problem is these Democratic
committees want you to do it on their time and on
their terms. I've reached out to many different
Democratic committees saying, can you give me a
list of Pennsylvania Democrats or Bucks County
Democrats, and I'll call them to get out the
vote. The reply is always, We don't do it that
way anymore, but we do it this way. They go on
to explain. They meet up on Zoom on a Saturday
or Sunday. Everyone does it together. I don't like
this. Give me a list of people and I'll call them.
If I get done the list, I'll come back for another
list. I feel like these Democratic committees are
getting in their own way. Yeah. Listen, I am
guessing that when it comes to phone stuff
and giving people information about people's
phone numbers or different things, there's
probably some privacy regulations that need to be
adhered to. But I agree with you, it can be way
too complicated to help. I've heard from a ton of
people who say I wanted to phone bank. They told
me first I've got to attend two different training
sessions via Zoom at really inconvenient times
to only get on the list. And then I needed to sign
up for a shift. I get it. Everybody has processes.
You've got to have a process. You've got to vet
people, all of it. But you're dissuading people
from doing it. There are people who would love
to phone bank, but they can't do two training
sessions during work hours. To only get to the
point where then they can pick a shift. So I do
think something needs to happen. I don't know
what it is, but I've heard that from a lot of
people. Dan wrote in about Jordan Peterson and
Jordan says, Why is it that nobody has pointed out
to Jordan Peterson and others like him that the
justification they use for religion, gender roles,
etc. are the same as those for the authoritarian
governments? He's literally saying society doesn't
function properly when people don't fit into
their prescribed role, all while lambasting
socialism and communism for their supposed lack
of freedoms. Not sure I'm making my point well,
but it's really kind of comical if you follow what
I'm getting at. I do. A lot of these folks like
Jordan Peterson say. Communism and socialism are
bad because they dictate how people should behave,
what type of job they should have. All of
these different norms. They take away freedom,
which capitalism leaves for people. But on the
other hand, they are extraordinarily authoritarian
in how they believe society should be prescribing,
whether it's gender roles or behavior or whatever
the case may be. That's absolutely true. If
you presented this to them, they would say.
Society is just a reflection of what the people
want, whereas a communist or socialist government
is an authoritarian imposition. And I do think
that that's valid. The problem is you can get
around that by saying, we're not communists and
socialists. We just want to elect people who
will actually do the things we want them to do.
And then it is much more equivalent to saying,
well, society or media or whatever. So. Good
luck explaining that to them. But it's a it's
a very good point. Shaina wrote in about
YouTube and says, Hey, David, I've had a
paid membership to your show for several years,
but just realized I'm not actually subscribe to
our YouTube channel I am now. Just thought
I'd mention it and encourage other people to
check. Love the show. Thanks for your excellent
work. Yes, there are two things going on. One.
Fandom unsubscribed. There are people who
genuinely were at some point subscribed to
YouTube and they report, I'm no longer subscribed.
I'm not claiming YouTube is unsubscribing. People
could be a glitch, could be anything. Double
check. And number two, there's tons of people who
see our clips on their home page on YouTube. So
they don't even think I need to do anything else.
Hit the subscribe, but it won't really change
anything. You're already seeing our clips,
but it is a really big deal for those subscriber
numbers to continue growing. It signals to YouTube
to keep recommending our clips to more people, so
I appreciate that very much. Shaina Neil wrote in
about something. A couple people called to
my attention and said, So on your discord,
it was brought to my attention that your Google
profile info comes up as conspiracy theorist,
which I find hilarious considering the time you've
spent dedicated to combating many conspiracy
theories that are harmful and unsupported.
One thing to note is Google pulls this from
your wiki page, which seems to be corrected. But
for me and everyone on the discord who checked,
it seemed to be pulling some old info. Yeah,
I saw this. Here's what's going on. There is
a fight happening on both my personal Wikipedia
page and the show. Wikipedia page. Essentially
with vandals. It's called vandalism on
Wikipedia where they just come through.
And because anybody can edit, they'll put in
anti-Semitic stuff about me or a conspiracy
theorist or whatever the case may be. It's
mostly caught automatically and fixed,
but every once in a while, like when it heats
up, the pages get locked so no one can edit.
Imagine having such a sad life that you go around
vandalizing Wikipedia pages. It's just it's really
pathetic. Mary wrote in about Mike pillow pillows
and says, Hey, David watched your show about using
Mike pillows. Pillows. They are awesome. I've had
mine for three years, works wonders for my neck.
However, he's a complete idiot and I will never
buy his pillows again. Yeah, people have written
in most. To be perfectly honest, most of the
people who write in say the pillows are not good.
But a couple people like Mary have written in and
said now that the guy's bonkers, but he does have
a good pillow. As I said during our interview,
I'm glad to try my pillow pillows. He said he was
sending them to me for me to review them and that
his assistant would reach out. Nobody ever reached
out. I didn't get the pillows, so make of it what
you will. But I'm still still waiting. Still glad
to try them. Not so concerned that I'm going to
go buy one myself. But if he sends one, I will try
it. Get your emails in info at David Pakman dot
com. We are now into the post 2022 midterm phase
and it's going to get very, very nuts. We have a
fantastic bonus show for you today. You can sign
up at join Packman Qcom. And next week we are.
We're hitting the ground running, that's for sure.